the pro football hall of fame weekend is
an annual celebration of the history of
the game
this year it has a special raiders
connection fans of the silver and black
will be paying
extra close attention to the induction
ceremony as two of the greatest who ever
wear the uniform takes center stage
john treach is here with more hi john
hey there yeah canton ohio is splashed
with the sentimental and the silver and
black there are only 354 members in
football's
most exclusive club among those getting
a brand new bronze bust
in the museum are raider great's tom
flores and charles woodson
our canton correspondent taylor brooks
caught up with one reflective raider
for raiders fans the time is almost here
tom flores and charles woodson
will both be inducted into the pro
football hall of fame on sunday
both will also get their gold jackets
here at the civic center in canton
tonight
and for woodson those raiders memories
will live on forever
as he remembers those who couldn't be
here this week with the raiders just
being drafted you know fourth overall
was a pretty big deal and to me it was
really all about the relationships and
the guys
that i was able to play alongside out
there legends of the game tim brown's
here
the only thing i'm missing here is
willie brown uh this time of year
i remember being on sidelines and he
would always leave and come to the hall
of fame this time of year during
training camp and then he'd come back
and tell me about it and say charles
i can't wait till you go in i'm gonna be
right there so i miss willie brown
this time of year sunday we will hear
woodson's speech but getting this gold
jacket is really the moment it all
becomes real
how to put a cap on it man and you know
to put that jacket on and to really
you know be solidified you know amongst
all of these greats man
it's been a great ride so charles
woodson and tom flores will both be
inducted into the pro football hall of
fame on
sunday and then on saturday the class of
2020
actually getting inducted as well as
entrement week was canceled last year
because of the pandemic reporting here
at the civic center in canton i'm taylor
brooks
and the last raider to be inducted into
the hall of fame it was in 2018 and that
was randy moss
yeah and both flores and woodson
continue to talk to current
players and make their imprint on the
organization because once a raider
always a raider